[Musique]
6h30
c'est le retour des vacances de
toussaint au collège des provinces
[Musique]
thierry dubois et son équipe doivent
préparer 680 repas au menu côté légumes
carottes râpées sellerie bio locaux en
entrée les pommes de terre pour l'apurer
sont déjà en train de cuire les pommes
de terre elles viennent de contre negi
murray qui nous lé travail qui ne les ai
plus qui nous lui mais solide pour nous
c'est un gain de temps parce que épluché
120 kg de pommes de terre le matin on
n'a pas spécialement le temps vaut mieux
mettre en cuisson en arrivant ça reste
traditionnel enfin après il faut se
donner les moyens de ont fait un
bourguignon comme à la maison ici il ya
que les volumes qui change quoi la pure
et vous verrez comme on l'a fait on la
fait pas manuellement mais aller comme à
la maison
un petit peu plus encore encore un peu
voilà merci dans cet établissement
l'équipe essaie d'utiliser un maximum de
produits locaux
mais ce n'est pas simple il ne faut pas
dépasser le prix journalier 2 euros par
assiette d'achat de denrées et il faut
s'y trouvaient et producteurs
on aimerait bien travailler un petit peu
plus souvent mais des preuves de
livraison
ben ils veulent pas se déplacer au delà
de tant de kilomètres
vous voyez comme par exemple les melons
on aurait bien aimé des melons de bil'in
qui se trouve pas loin de 12 ans le
marché mais et nous leur délivrons pas
sur la région devoir aller les pommes
oui l'état mais qu'est ce heureusement
quelques agriculteurs locaux sont
fidèles ce producteur de pommes vient de
mont près chambord à 15 km le blois ils
livrent entre 80 et 100 kg de ses fruits
au collège chaque début de semaine cela
représente 10% de sa production
il ya longtemps que je trouverai que les
collèges et l'autre toujours en direct
et en bois peut-être plus fois dans le
monde est peut-être plus une garantie
pour nous une garantie on est sûr de
rendre toujours au même prix toujours
pareil le prix des pommes locales et non
traité 1 en euros 20 le kilo l'équipe de
la cuisine des provinces aimeraient ne
travailler qu'avec ce genre de produits
c'est tout le défi du projet de
plateforme du conseil départemental
proposé au collège un service de
livraison fiable et un réseau
d'agriculteurs labellisé avec des
produits locaux de qualité
[Musique]